Why is Aluminum Foil Shiny on One Side But
Not the Other?
The most abundant metal in the Earth’s crust,
aluminum naturally occurs as a compound with
other elements, such as aluminum oxide or
potassium aluminum sulfate.
As such, it was not isolated as a separate
element until 1825 when a Danish chemist,
Hans Christian Oersted, was able to produce
a small amount.
By 1845, a German chemist, Friedrich Wöhler,
had perfected a way of producing enough aluminum
to be able to study it.
In 1854, the French chemist, Henri Étienne
Sainte-Claire Deville improved on Wöhler’s
method and developed a process to commercially
produce the element, although it still remained
expensive, even more than gold.
Other improvements were made independently
by chemists Charles Martin Hall (American)
and Paul L.T.
Héroult (French) in 1886, and by Karl Joseph
Bayer (Austrian) in 1888.
As a result, sufficiently large quantities
of aluminum oxide were now able to be produced
from bauxite, and then aluminum could easily
be obtained from the aluminum oxide.
This greatly reduced the cost of aluminum,
and in 1888, Charles Martin Hall formed the
precursor to the Aluminum Company of America
(Alcoa), the Pittsburgh Reduction Company.
Production methods continued to improve and
by 1909, the Pittsburgh company’s output
was at 41,000 kg per day.
By 1910, the first manufacturing plant for
the production of aluminum foil opened in
Emmishofen, Switzerland by Dr. Lauber, Neher
& Cie.
So why is aluminum foil shiny on one side
and not as much on the other?
In what is called the Bayer Process, after
pure molten aluminum is obtained from aluminum
oxide, it is placed in furnaces with a small
amount of other elements (typically the final
product will be between 99.8% and 99.9% aluminum).
This liquid is then poured into “chill casting
devices where it cools into large slabs called
‘ingots.'”
Next the ingot is treated with heat (annealed),
and then rolled between heavy rollers.
This initial foil is sent through still more
rollers, several times, until it reaches the
desired thinness.
For the type of foil that is bright on one
side and matte on the other, it is so thin
that during some of the last rollings, two
sheets of the thin foil must be placed together
lest they tear or crimp during the final rolling
of the sheets.
One consequence of this is that while the
sides that touch the highly polished rollers
are burnished to a bright finish, the inner
sides that touch the other aluminum foil remain
matte.
Bonus Foil Facts:
• Before aluminum became cheap and readily
available, during the last part of the 19th
and early 20th centuries, a type of thin foil,
used commercially, was actually made of tin
(tin foil).
Because of the popularity of this foil, today
many call aluminum foil this name.
• More than just packaging, aluminum can
be used to polish silver: after lining a deep
pan with foil, cover it with cold water and
add a couple of teaspoons of salt and your
silverware.
Chemistry (magic) will remove the tarnish.
A similar process can be used to clean jewelry,
except exchange the cold water for hot, and
the salt for a tablespoon of laundry detergent.
Likewise, a sheet of aluminum foil underneath
freshly polished silverware will deter tarnishing.
• Scissors can be sharpened by cutting through
several layers of aluminum foil
a few times.